[Music]
I got rear-ended and I couldn't use my
right hand for anything intricate
wasn't really until I started finding
these ways to work around it that I got
my passion back and my positivity back
for music it's just a unique thing to
hear a software controlling something so
physical people think that there might
be a ghost playing
my name is ólafur Arnalds I am a
producer songwriter composer from
Iceland I approached my music like an
electronic producer I work in the
computer with a lot of synthesizers and
drum machines but I'm using classical
instruments like strings and piano
[Music]
I do like to bring all these traditional
sounds of strings of woodwinds physical
instruments that are so expressive
so emotive into an environment that is a
little bit more accessible for most
people the Stratos is a software that I
created with my friend and this software
creates generative algorithms that are
meant to control these two self playing
pianos
[Music]
if sampling pianos have been around for
ages I always thought there's a
beautiful piece of technology there that
is only being used to playback music but
not necessarily being used very much to
create music I insert notes and the
software reads those notes so it knows
what chord I'm playing so it's note off
the cord gets its own rhythm tempo time
signature and everything if you give
each note just a very like random number
not in any sort of 4/4 type of signature
that's when you get these things that
sound totally random but actually
they're not they're just very complex
mathematics there's a lot of accidental
patterns that happen along the way which
I then listen to and grab on to if I
hear something interesting and then I
can build the song from those accidental
patterns this is my song unfold from my
new album remember
[Music]
the song started with me just kind of
improvising and playing around with this
Stratos software and seeing what the
randomized elements the software is
throwing at me and grabbing on to some
of those ideas
[Music]
I decided to put staccato strings as
kind of the main other element in the
first half of the song and then the
woodwinds bring the tension to it I
think what provides a very interesting
contrast here I asked these string
players to play as robotically as they
could but on the other hand we have this
element which is made by a software and
that element actually becomes more human
than what the humans are playing on the
strings and that provides the kind of
emotional aspect of the song
[Music]
so when I was younger I was in a band
called fighting [ __ ] we were like trash
punk band I played drums we went at it
pretty hard
we've made a lot of Records and kind of
metal career out of that
I became interested in classical music
mostly through my grandparents who were
very big classical music listeners but
it wasn't really until I discovered film
scores that I wanted to make it not
really having the musical education to
back it up my creations became very
simplistic loopy versions of that that
are actually more related to modern pop
music I think the result is what became
neoclassical music is basically people
trying to make classical music but not
really knowing how to do the most
important thing I took from punk music
was the DIY ethos of everything
nothing was relying on management or
labels we really believe in doing things
ourselves so then when I started doing
classical music I kept that ethos you
know I was doing completely different
kind of music suddenly but nothing in my
head actually changed I kept booking the
same kind of venues I was touring with
my punk bands but just bringing our
string quartet and a small electric
keyboard so once I had this idea which
is the piano the staccato strings and
then the woodwinds supporting it that's
when I started adding more complementary
things like the bass line
which is actually a polyphonic Korg
keyboard there's a melody that can
alternate between piano that I actually
play not an automatic piano and then
some legato parts in the woodwinds and
that was kind of enough to have that
very simple melody to kind of give the
song a little bit of meaning because of
how the rhythms of the pianos are kind
of unpredictable I felt the empty toilet
paper roll with a bunch of rice and hit
it with a drumstick and that kind of
helps the pianos defying the rhythm a
little bit
yeah it's a little bit ironic that
you're complimenting very expensive nice
real instruments with the roll of toilet
paper
[Music]
he got rear-ended something that happens
all the time but they were spying semi
truck so it was a bit harsh
[Music]
after that I suffered some nerve damage
in my spine and I couldn't use my right
hand for anything intricate for like a
year or year and a half I couldn't play
piano it was heartbreaking to me it was
really difficult I felt a horribly
depressed almost and that ended up
really setting this idea completely in
stone to use these self playing piano so
I could play chords but I couldn't play
any scales or like individual notes so
that influenced how we programmed
Stratos to react to me entering chords
and turning them into textures and
rhythms it gave me a little bit of a
purpose to be creating something without
having to use my hands that much that
whole thing from life activity
[Music]
instead of building to a traditional
peak it actually builds up and then
suddenly drops down I came up with this
idea of adding a traditional hip-hop 808
bass drum into it which you don't hear
very often in classical music so at the
same time as this big fat hip of kick
drum comes in the pianos become so soft
[Music]
my friend the singer-songwriter song he
came over and I showed him the very
early demo of this song and he just
started singing and this like beautiful
angelic choir arrangement came out
totally on the spot
Oh
who
for me the creative process you can you
can look at it like the circle of life
it's not just one thing that finishes
there's always a continuation of it
so the song is very much about that
circle birth and the rebirth of
creativity
[Music]
strattice and this whole idea is just a
tool that gives me another sound that I
wouldn't be able to make otherwise it's
not supposed to replace humans in any
way because music is about saying
something it's about expressing
something and the computer isn't trying
to say anything
music without meaning is nothing
[Music]